hello everyone and welcome we're glad
you've joined us for this live webinar
laboratory automation to deliver
reliable results faster presented by dr.
Stefan over camp I'm Christina Joel
elaborate and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational
seminar is presented by lab roots the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning this webinar
is sponsored by beckman coulter beckman
coulter is dedicated to advancing and
optimizing the laboratory the company's
global leadership and world-class
service and support deliver
sophisticated instrument systems
reagents and services to life science
researchers in academics and commercial
laboratories enabling new discoveries in
biology based research and development
for more information please visit www
and com now let's get started the
seminar is designed to be interactive
you can submit questions to the speaker
at any time during the presentation to
do so simply click the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window and type them into the Q&A box
questions will be answered after the
presentation and we will answer as many
questions as we have time for if by
chance we weren't able to get to your
question your question will be answered
via email following the presentation you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window click
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problems like clicking on
the green Q&A button at lower left this
is an educational webinar and thus
offers free continuing education credits
after the webinar is over please click
on the c/e button located in the
bottom left hand corner of your web page
and follow the process of obtaining your
credits our speaker today is dr. Stefan
over camp senior field marketing manager
for beckman coulter life sciences dr.
Stefan over camp has over 15 years of
automation cell culture and molecular
biology experience he received his PhD
in molecular biology from the University
of Munster where he trained with a focus
on biochemistry and molecular biology a
plant pathogen defense I will now turn
my presentation over to dr. Stefan over
camp dr. to over camp yes thank you
Christina and welcome everyone everyone
I'd like to thank lab roots for giving
me the opportunity to speak here about
laborator laboratory automation and how
that enables to deliver deliver reliable
results faster if we look at the agenda
I I want to start with a brief
introduction on laboratory automation
how we achieve higher throughput through
parallel processing how is achieve more
efficient see through longer hands of
time and how we deliver reliable data
through increased reproducibility and
integrated data handling after this
introduction I want to give you a couple
of examples from two fields of
application one from to genomics
workflows and one from cellular
workflows and in the end after the
summary we have some time for a Q&A
session and I'm looking forward to your
questions on laboratory automation so
for the intro how do we achieve higher
throughput well the key to higher
throughput usually is parallel
processing and if you look at how you
handle samples in your laboratory at the
bench it's usually performed using
single channel or sometimes a channel
pipettors all that is available in
laboratory automation as well but on top
of that laboratory automation does offer
the user a higher degree of parallel
processing with for example 96 or even
384 channel
ads when it comes to high-throughput or
even outright throughput applications
such as screening for example or
high-throughput genomic extractions
these systems enable a a significant
speed advantage and I'm just giving you
a very simple example down here which is
filling a 384-well plate with ten
microliters of a buffer from a reservoir
which takes using a single channel
approximately 52 minutes while using an
a channel you are already down to eight
minutes if you use a 96 channel you're
down to a good one minute and with a 384
channel it's it's below 1 minute you can
actually see here that at the 384
channel had usage this is the most of
the time is not the actual pipetting
because the difference between 96 and
384 is so small but most of the time is
is used for loading the tips actually
because this is scenario is done with
disposable tips so if you have multiples
of these plates instead of filling a
single one the advantage would be even
much more significant where does this
give you a real benefit well there are
certain types of applications that are
usually that are usually requiring lots
of pipetting steps and have a lot of
samples at the same types and typical
applications would realize those cell
based assays self-sustaining essays
typical biochemical assays compound
management co dilutions plate
replications i threw up with DNA and RNA
extractions and high-throughput
next-generation library preparations
also laboratory automation offers more
efficiency through longer hands of time
so the tricycle work at the lab bench
does require the researcher well
actually to be at the lab to perform
this this research and this pipetting
automation systems of different levels
of complexity actually do allow to
automate full workflows instead of only
the liquid hand
itself or processes are processing of
multiple plates because liquid handling
systems of today they cannot just do
pipetting they can also store a lab
where's library supply reagent supply
they can move lab where around trigger
integrated devices for such processes
such as thermal cyclers or readers and
the advanced software methods they will
execute the pipetting and other tasks to
complete a full method successfully and
when I say full method for example here
I'm looking at an NGS library
preparation where if you do all of that
manually you can probably generate up to
a libraries with a full day of hands-on
time manually but in an automated
fashion we are able to generate 96
libraries with less than two hours
hands-on time so you're not just getting
more libraries you're also freeing up
six hours of your working time to do
more interesting work for example
interpreting these data and drawing
scientific conclusions from these data
very important is also that the data you
are generating in your experiments are
reliable but they actually do reflect
biology rather than experimental
conditions so automation helps
generating reliable data in increasing
reproducibility and it also helps by
allowing for integrated data handling
automated liquid handling or automated
laboratory processing is controlled by
computers and the primary automation
control software is built on a database
and what that means is that data
handling basically is in its DNA so
whenever in biomech we do pipe it
liquids we also virtually pipe at the
data and at the image to the right you
can see that these data can be a lot of
things not just sample ID but
concentrations or the actual protocol
you are running the the source plate
betcha
etcetera etcetera on top of that
automated liquid handlers also drive
reproducibility day in and day out they
are a machine right they do not have a
bad monday after after an exciting
weekend or anything like that they can
work overnight the usually this effect
again plays if you are looking at
thousands or even tens of thousands of
samples more efficiently versus if
you're looking at a tour or 12 samples I
mean a very experienced ta can get very
good results with respect to
reproducibility if if that person does
prepare let's say eight or 16 NGS
libraries but if you gotta prepare 96 or
484 of these libraries usually the
laboratory automation approach gives you
a much higher degree of reproducibility
okay so that was just a brief
introduction and I'd like to now
continue with some examples of genomic
workflows so I've picked next-gen
library as an example and before I go
into details I just want to give you a
high-level overview of what typical NGS
workflow is so basically it can be
broken down into into these parts that
you do see here if you're starting with
terror is RNA you would start with a
cdna synthesis upfront to to turn RNA
into DNA then the actual library
construction does happen an optional you
can enrich that library by applying pcr
and you can limit the segment of the
nucleic acid you are looking at by doing
a target capture and then finally you
have the library QC and the actual
sequencing happen the thing about NGS
sample preparation or NGS library
construction is that the specific
workflow dependent on your kit that you
are using and
sample material and your sequencing
interest it can it can vary greatly it's
going to be a single day short and
simple but it can also be mounted
multi-day highly complex protocols
common elements of such a workflow are
reagent and enzyme transfers sample
transfers be based sample cleanup and or
site selection and thermal cycling and
incubation and if we look at a couple of
examples just on how complex these are I
have three examples to you see here to
the less you have the rubicon genomics
through Plex plasma seek that is a
process that gives you a library in
approximately three and a half hours it
uses a single plate for our reactions
but it has a limited number of start and
stop point points to the right you see a
workflow of the alumina true technology
and a word protocol this protocol takes
already a full day it has multiple
reaction and clean up lights and
multiple start and stop points but we
can go even further so what we see here
is another kid from another to seek are
an axis that takes full three days to
give you a library it includes target
capture it includes large number of lab
where and consumables and it is a very
complex workflow with numerous start and
stop points so you can see NGS library
prep even though high level it's pretty
simple if you if you're going down to
the detail it can be very complex and
variability is significant so what are
the challenges of manual NGS sample
preparation well first of all there is a
pretty significant amount of manual
pipetting steps so there's high
variability so for example inefficient
adapter cleanup can occur the sample you
can be very very different and very
significantly it does require skilled
pipetting for example the accurate
so viscous liquids the etl tip mixing
and the preventing of the carrier or
magnetic beads and because of that and
because it takes such a long hands-on
period it is prone to user fatigue and
injury by that it is easy that users do
introduce errors in that process for
example sample or index transfer mix-ups
sample normalization errors mastermix
receive calculation errors pipec pipette
volume settings errors and overall the
the throughput is limited and that means
you're facing reduced data generation
limited personnel resources because you
could do parallel processing as I
mentioned before by not using automation
but using multiple TAS but usually that
is too costly and that those people are
not available and there's more effort
spend on routine sampling processing
versus the actual data analysis which
usually is the more exciting part of
science automation can help to minimize
or even eliminate these challenges and
here is a couple of examples no we start
with some some things we hear in our
everyday work talking to customers a lot
of our customers when we approached them
about automation give us a response that
they saying hey we're too small for
automation well you're never too small
for automation because automation is not
necessarily only targeted at high
throughput automation does reduce the
effort of routine processing and does
increase productivity even with limited
personnel resources if you have one
person that does actually understand to
run a biomech or a liquid handler that
already gives you a significant increase
in efficiency we also often fear that
the throughput would not be high enough
to justify automation again the key
point to adapt automation is more on the
accuracy and reproducibility of sample
data because that is what matters in
science right
if you do not have good data if you
don't have reproducible and accurate
data any any scientific conclusion a
slot or is possibly not correct also
here that people do trust people more
than machines well what we deliver
especially in the context of NGS is not
just a liquid handler we do know that
these methods do need to be qualified by
knowledgeable people and we're
cooperating with the kid vendors and
with some key users in the field to
demonstrate and do actually qualify with
data or methods that we do deliver we
also hear that the budgets are limited
well sure in the end we will send an
invoice and ask for some money but
automation overall can provide
significant savings over manual
processing through reducing the labor
costs and the overtime pay reduce the
rework that is caused by human error and
actually reduce the consumable usage by
using efficient labware and tip handling
and the final objective we often hear is
we don't have the expertise to operate
and maintain laboratory automation and
this is an important one I have to say
because if you look around in the field
you can see a lot of automation systems
that are no longer used for that reason
but biomech software is a full-featured
but easy-to-use which makes it simple
for the right solution to be executed
and on top of that and I'll get to that
in a couple of slides we are offering
what we call the biomech method launcher
a very simplistic user interface so if a
user has no intent to modify or change
any of the methods it's basically
bringing the system down to a
push-button solution also for different
types of requirements with respect to
throughput with availability of budget
we we can offer different platforms that
enable the automation of such processes
as NGS sample prep to the left you do
see or entry-level liquid handler which
is the biomat 4000 the size is just
right for a low to medium throughput
labs so let's say if you're producing 12
24 libraries at a time it does offer a
pot with interchangeable pipetting tools
singer and a channel which gives you
full flexibility with respect to the
number of samples you want to process so
our protocols do not force you to use
eight or 16 or 24 samples at the same
time but you can have continuously any
number of samples being processed on
that system it comes with an optional
enclosure that allows you to protect
your samples from any interference of
airborne particles from the laboratory
to the right you see the biomechanics it
is for medium to high throughput up to
96 it comes in two variations one with a
spinning one with a multi-channel and
that really depends what is more
important to you flexibility or
throughput and it has 16 positions high
customizable deck with increased
capacity the final one and the high end
solution is the biomech FX platform it
is high throughput complex workflows and
can process up to 96 samples at the same
time it can be configured with a
combination of two parts a multi-channel
and Aspen eight so combining flexibility
and high throughput and has an even
larger deck with more than 20 positions
that allows us to store the lab where
required for for really complex work
feels okay so what else is important if
we're looking at NGS workflows well it's
definitely about excessive accessories
and integrated device options led by
selection heating cooling orbital shaker
tip mixing tube usage if we look at that
lab West selection you want to make a
decision if you're using tubes versus
plates what type of reagent both of us
are required
plays and beat separation enter thermal
cycler leads which is an important part
if you are looking into integrated
thermal cycling shaking so it is a fast
and efficient plate mixing for mostly
beat separations it reduces tube usage
and it provides very uniform results on
the other hand tip mixing works very
well for large large volumes it does
prevent the cross contamination with
with lebra that is filled at or near the
well capacity and you can access tubes
or leg we're not comforted compatible
with orbital shakers on that heating
cooling so there's two options basically
you can have a heater or cooler on with
a party that has no ceiling or does not
require any ceiling but it has a low
ramping and cooling speed and it's not
idea for all applications especially
with higher temperatures on the other
hand your other options is a thermal
cycler it can be integrated on all
platforms that I present it to you
couple of slides ago it does provide
true walk away solution because it runs
its own protocol it prevent evaporation
to fight ceiling lids and it is
compatible with come and use pcr legwear
also important is the tip type and you
got to make decisions on the various
volume ranges whether you want to use
sterile with barrier or non barrier
whether you want to use conductive or
not conductive for liquid level sending
and if you do need to access and what
these tubes sizes would be so we also
have a couple of options on the actual
method workflow so for example you can
decide whether you want to do on deck or
optic thermal cycling so even though we
do have the option to integrate thermal
cyclers we can definitely offer
integrating just by the workflow off
deck thermal cycling you can work in a
training mode that means you can only
run
protocol with water basically no samples
just to test it you can have all
relevant application specific options
being chosen you have the option
validation and you have safe stop points
for example safe let us point where you
can safely store the intermediate
product you can have people's pcr break
points and these storage coins also do
allow for off deck incubations and they
allow for recovery also important is how
you handle chemistry on deck for example
in this case it's naoh which is present
in some hybridization and capture NGS
methods such as the alumina next hour
epic capture it is used to denature the
captured library and reuse it from the
set of 18 beats it can also absorb co2
from the atmosphere if it's set open on
the deck for an extended period of time
and thus change pH so it's important to
protect that for example so now down to
a real example of what we actually do
I'm focusing here on DNA sequencing and
specifically on whole genome sequencing
why would you do to whole genome
sequencing well it's basically used for
characterization of genetic variations
mutations across the organisms de novo
sequencing resequencing slip variants
etc etc so there is a two ways to get to
libraries once the whole genome
sequencing library preparation has you
you see it here you start with a
fragment or fragmentation you do an end
repair and a tailing and after ligation
and pcr enrichment the purpose is to
obtain as much of the genome as possible
generally genomes at 20 times coverage
are considered finished and can be used
for molecular biology applications there
is a different way of doing this which
is the technician which uses transpose
ohms which basically gives you the same
thing a fragmented library that is good
for
sequencing purposes the challenges
challenges with whole genome sequencing
is you do need to accommodate a wide
range of sample inputs you also need the
ability to accurately sized select
across a wide range of fragment sizes
and a lot of these protocols are complex
and lengthy and they require extensive
hand on time and sample manipulation
what you see here is one example of the
true see DNA pcr free nano DNA kit from
alumina its automated on the entry level
platform the biomech 4000 is also
automated in other platforms it does
combined to sequencing chemistry into a
one streamline method and it does
accommodate a range of 100 nanogram to
talk to microgram input range and you
can see these work flow diagrams here to
the right where basically the true cdna
free just rusev DNA pcr free sorry
comprises these first two columns if you
wish and the true cigna no DNA includes
this second or third with a pcr
amplification and pc action network as
well if you look at how we handle this
with respect to interacting between the
user and the and the actual sample
method you can see that goodbye Mike
4000 does provide similar method option
selects ability as an X and ethics it's
optimized for low input and throughput
laboratories it's scalable 296 sample
workflows if you want to increase from
the be 4k to another platform so this is
what it looks like we have a set of two
of single and a channel pipetting tools
to provide a balance of precious reagent
delivery and efficient cleanups we use
only three tip boxes for the whole
process we have the reagents control the
four degrees celsius and the deck is
flexible enough to allow for a thermal
cycler integration which is not shown
here
that should be required this is some
results we're getting with respect to
yield and purity so these are
bioanalyzer data that are produced and
you can see that these are very very
clean and that the that the youth is
definitely high enough to generate good
sequencing results total run time here
on the be 4k is for a temple seven and a
half hour for 48 samples eight hours and
496 sample 9.5 hours so you can see with
an increased number of samples the
efficiency that laboratory automation
gets to sample processing really pays
off there is another process we're
looking at which is Swift Biosciences
the X 0 ng s 2 s plus it does provide a
PC are free or optional pcr workflow and
we have on deck thermal cycling optional
and we can generate 96 pcr foreverly
libraries in approximately four and a
half hours again this is this is the
interface that gives you a lot of
options to select from four examples
whether or not you want to do PCR pcr
enrichment we will definitely adjust
describe lead ratios with respect to the
sample and input and so on and so forth
if we look at the results getting from
that you see that samples were used in
this in this test will generate
sufficient library for sequencing code
sequencing results and these are
sequencing results that you are seeing
we have variable fragment length that we
can produce we have a wide range of
sample inputs from 100 picogram to 500
nanogram we have an extremely low pcr
duplicate rate and a very good coverage
of the sequence and this is for FFPE
samples and you can basically see the
same same thing that the FFPE sample
mighty Rio does produce sufficient here
for sequencing and again gives extremely
low pcr duplicates these are only two
examples a full overview of the methods
available in
library prep you will find in a method
cut and that should be available for
download for you today if you click the
blue arrow that gives you access to some
PDF files some more information detailed
information I put together for you but
what about the user experience so are
you sure we pick the right project am I
using the most recent version of my
methods 0 at x or normal biomech
operator is on vacation and my p.i wants
me to run this essay so what do I do so
basically we introduced the second level
of operation this one here is the
standard biomech software that's
basically designed for you to be able to
design and modify methods but very often
you don't need that so if you only want
to execute method we've introduced a
biomech method launcher and this is the
interface that you're seeing so it will
easily allow you to find the correct
method to your left or if needed well by
a manual control being the liquid hands
are in a state that it can execute the
method so with biomech method launcher
you get a very easy interface that gives
you an insight that you have selected
the correct method of choice the number
of samples and some variations that you
can easily input here it also has a
guided lab we're set up making sure that
all pieces of lab where that you need to
put on the deck are taken care of in the
correct order and when you finally run
the system it has a very nice runtime
interface that gives you an up-to-date
view on the status of the actual method
execution at the same time we're taking
care of data handling and again is this
you've seen before there's a lot of data
we call them datasets that can be
associated to a sample or a well which
is not just the simple ID it could be a
project ID it could be the p.i it could
be the species of the sample and so on
the volume reagent lot time stands lab
where type liquid type accessorize that
all of that can be handled and tricked
and used automatically in the software
that we provide with our liquid handling
systems samples or sample data do come
from multiple sources in such a process
so for example they come from barcode
reading of sample single tubes from EXO
files etc etc so the first step usually
is we we merge sample data to plate
recording everything and then in the
process for example readers will
generate data for normalization if you
wish we need to merge the detector data
trick and track the data and the simple
ID to the dilution play then we merge
the sample and lot with more processed
data as we use different types of
reagent and then finally we need to
export these data to alumina experiment
manager on the sample sheet or export
these data to a Lim's for downstream
analysis the tools we are providing is
called dart the data acquisition and
repository tool and that allows to store
and merge data from different sources
it's running on a separate database so
you can run it on a separate computer
giving you security on the data that
they are safely store it can also be
viewed on mobile devices and it can
connect to lymph systems what you can do
is you have the data query builder that
does allow you to get an insight into
the bees data based on web web based on
sample based on one that gives you an
immediate and life overview of the data
that are currently in the database on
any piece of lab where and you have also
the option to generate reports here's
the reports builder to your right and
above you see a report that is ready to
be imported by the alumina experiment
manager so you can modify the reports
just so that they are easily connected
to other devices or other data handling
units in your laboratory that was
what I wanted to present on genomics and
we're now moving on to cell culture so
culture have specific challenges and the
reason for that is that cells are just
living things they have specific needs
to continue to live and grow happening
while in genomics we're usually working
with chemistry or molecules well here
cells need to be treated differently
they require very gentle pipetting they
do need appropriate room to grow they
need sufficient nutrients they need
appropriate growth conditions and the
cell processes are different in a way
that they usually take multiple days
often weeks and sometimes even month to
complete you have longer periods of
incubation interrupting actual liquid
handling tasks and each individual cell
line or clone may grow at a different
rate and have different requirements
with respect to the media so let's talk
about cell culture process control so
our culture is a process rather than a
method to execute the challenge is it is
often required to automate a full
process that does consist of multiple
tasks and they are broken up and
separated by longer periods of
incubation standard liquid handling
control software or even schedulers to
struggle to handle such lengthy and
complex processes we have introduced a
new layer taking care of this which is
called sami Process Management and that
does allow the user to build and manage
their own processes to run multiple
processes in parallel on one single
system to manage the system capacity and
manage all data handling for all lab
where and samples and I want to give you
an example and here's the example
context which is a real system this is
real system consists of a liquid handler
which in this case is the bio magnetics
it's got a couple of components that we
do require for facilitating the actions
of the process such as tilting and
knocking incubations sterility cell
counting confluency measurements and
transportation and incubation of these
plates
if you look at the layout this is the
actual layer of the system how it's all
go together to the left here you see the
actual liquid and mother biomech FX and
then all the other devices that we just
that we've just seen in the previous
slide are integrated so that means we
can move plates with this scar arm
across the system we can bring them from
one station to another execute whatever
we need to execute for example read out
of a confluency measurement here at the
cell ago and then have them in
controlled in an integrated way so they
work together as a workstation that
allows us to process plates with all
devices as needed so and so that was the
hardware context and context of the real
scenario here is this is this is the
process we're trying to automate we have
a manual start with starting with frozen
cell lines these are then seeded and
then these cells go on earth system and
we continuously maintain these cells so
we measure the confluency based on those
data we do media exchange or splitting
the cells and this is happening
continuously for 40 different cell lines
in parallel at the same time the user is
able to order cells for their
experiments and if that order comes in
instead of just splitting cells we will
then upscale the cell number so
increasing the number of cells and
harvesting the cells and make them
available for experiments in 96 or
384-well plates per cell line per order
request and here is a breakdown of one
process which is splitting and massaging
the cells so basically what you got to
do here is you got to remove the
supernatant you gotta wash it you got at
trips in you gotta separate the cells
you count the cells you dilute on a new
plate and the discard the supernatant of
all plates each one of these steps is a
single method on a liquid handler okay
so how do we integrate that two or four
processes you've seen in the previous
slide high-level well what you do is
down here you have your liquid handler
methods there then together make a sammy
method a scheduled method that takes
multiple of these liquid handling
actions into a method and then multiple
of these methods like media exchange and
passaging make a process that is defined
and managed in summary process
management and data handling in the
background just as we've seen in the NGS
field is taking care of all the data
handling in the background so it's
really bottom-up taking care of all the
details but also taking care of the
high-level process control just a few
examples this is how the process is
built in the sámi process editor your
own process can have menu tasks it can
have scheduler methods it can have
single liquid handler methods it can
have incubations and data queries if you
start new plates you can start them in a
calendar the system schedules new tasks
on the calendar and it begins the first
task perhaps for example seeding cells
if you start new plates you do the same
thing as you did before in the calendar
but the system now looks at conflicts
and ones of weekend evening requirements
for example conflicts would be if you're
overloading an incubator or if you're
want to run the same time let's say on a
device like a reader at the same time
for different plates and you got to
solve these conflicts against all of
these conflicts in the calendar this is
the calendar overview interleaving
multiple processes each process is
indicated by a different color it has a
monthly overview and it has a daily
overview and again you can move things
around so very often you have incubation
times of the day or two but it doesn't
really matter to the hour
so just by simply moving eight hours a
little bit a couple of hours to ahead or
behind very often those already help you
to solve a conflict also in cell culture
it is very important that each
individual well does count cleansing
automation control software is designed
to handle pieces of lab where in cell
culture every cell line which is
represented by a well maybe different
different growth rates different media
supplement requirements expansion
splitting and sorry process management
does exactly that it controls the
process by the well as we've heard
before by Omega automation software has
data handing in its DNA so we can now
use this data in the database the
datasets that do describe the properties
of each individual well we can use them
now online to control method execution
and family closest management does
introduce the concept of well groups it
is a virtual entity multiple wales welds
that do share a property or multiple
properties that are on a single piece of
metal or in multiple different pieces on
lepre can be defined as a well group and
then wells can be added and removed from
this world group throughout the process
the task event actually executed on this
well group and no longer on a piece of
lab where so that means for example to
define these groups you can query in
family probs management the database so
you can ask for properties all types of
properties that are stored in the
database right so I give you an example
you have for example 6 well 5 6 well
plates with 30 different clones you read
the confluency after three days one
third of the world's spread across all
these plates to exceed a threshold that
you have defined for splitting slimy
process management will now create a new
word group split the clones that are few
and incubate the others forever you will
repeat the same procedure the next day
and the worlds that are growing
the threshold overnight and only those
will now be split infirmaries automating
leverage our laboratory processes can
help to increase throughput and
reproducibility it can have to remove
human error reduce hands-on time and
allow to work more efficiently as you
have seen and this is just an an
introduction Beckman code that does
offer a right a wide range of hardware
software and integrations and
applications to enable successful and
fast implementation of automated
solutions in your lab what we've seen
that our current field of life science
laboratory research have shown to in the
past to benefit from applying automated
approaches with respect to speed and to
data quality the key to success is more
in smart ways to control automation by a
software and develop and support methods
as the hardware itself because the
hardware technology these days is very
mature across across the market and not
to forget if you are using multiple
samples integrated data handling as part
of the automated process is fundamental
to generate reliable results in all
areas of applications and with that I
thank the audience for their attention
darling interface and I'm opening up for
any questions I'm looking for watch true
answer these thank you dr. over camp for
that informative presentation I would
like to give our audience a quick
reminder on how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window we
will answer as many questions as time
permits ok dr. over camp our first
question is accurate pipetting is
important to all liquid handling tasks
how does Beckman address this and how
complex is it for the you
to handle does it require scripting but
that's that's a very good question
absolutely I mean besides everything
that I've presented today I mean there
is the fundament of very accurate by
petting that every liquid handling
system needs to provide that as used to
automate processes and generate reliable
data do we handle that in a biomech
software is we have something we call
pipetting templates and these pipetting
templates are basically something a user
can easily define just as writing a
method so its icon driven and all
operations that define the pipetting
like the move of the pipetting tip in
the well the actual pipetting speech
delays etc etc everything that you would
automatically do manually your brain
adapts the pipetting operation to the
pipetting context all of that is in the
pipetting template and that definitely
goes beyond liquid types we have liquid
types but we can make these pipetting
templates specific for any operation if
we want or for any context such as a
volume such as a sample type such as a
lab where type etc etc and it does not
require any scripting over camp do you
work with alumina and others for new kid
automated method development yes we do
so we are a partner to alumina and
others like any ve or swiftor rubicon
and we have joined efforts so basically
we are helping them to when when new
kids come out or established kids are we
are helping them with our own
experienced applications support to come
up with new methods automated methods
very quickly and we also develop methods
in house and generate data which are
then validated with these vendors and we
also receive input from their side what
is important and what are the little
details that need to be taken care of to
get good results with their kids and
chemistry's we're
open so we're not exclusive to anyone
and we will be in the future as well and
if you are looking at the full list of
methods that we have already automated
on our systems you can see that really
there is a pretty significant variety of
vendors that we're cooperating with ella
t or containment and cellular workflow
yeah some of our workflows arm sterility
again is is a big point a big concern
for a lot of our customers and there's
there's two different approaches
basically it all depends on the actual
size of the instrumentation you are
using so if if we're down to a very
streamlined simple be 4k that's used for
some basic liquid handling cars in a
cellular process you can probably put
that in a classical bezel to laminar
flow hood that's small enough for larger
systems we do actually cooperate with
manufacturers to build custom enclosures
and there are different variations
available so sterility we're actually
offering help I enclosures ourselves but
if you want a real class 100 with a
certification we would cooperate with
manufacturers of such enclosures it also
allows us to go one step further into
biological sectors so we can offer be as
a two or even full content visa three
enclosures or containments that do allow
the users to work with infectious
particles in these systems as well more
than fluency is it possible to count
style in a wall in a well yes that is
possible to counsel in a well again it's
it's not so much a feature of the
automation it is more efficient of the
integrated device itself so if the
device offers that that option we can
definitely do that in an automated
fashion as well and on top of that what
we very often do if we need to do the
cell counting is we do if it's adherent
cells we detach them and we use a cell
counter so we apply a little aliquot to
a cell counter such as the bank makoto
by cell and then do a cell counting and
do calculate the total cell number or
concentration of cells per volume in
that well you automate transaction yes
we have we have a lot of examples where
we have successfully automated
transaction and there's different ways
of transactions so we have automated
transaction using chemicals so
transactional reagents we have used
biological transaction with viruses and
we have also used electroporation by
integrating electro paratus so all
different ways the efficiency is usually
very very good it does benefit from the
reproducibility you get with the liquid
that liquid handling automated across a
plate so there's there's multiple of
examples where this is worked very well
and there are publications out there
scientific publications not beckman
coulter application notes where you can
find that infectious disease we've
studies at the Max Planck Institute in
Berlin co-infection disease which have
conducted major screens on as I RNA and
the transection rates that they got
there are published in in those papers
elaborate on that question we have an
audit services we would like to automate
the transaction process and also the
core cell culture facility where we
handle multiple cell lines could you
provide more information on that yes
absolutely probably not in this Q&A
session because it's it's really down to
the detail so if that user is willing to
give their contact details will
definitely be in contact with them
because of the first step to a
successful automation really is a very
good understanding of that process and
again in all detail because in the end
it is the detail that will
make the difference between a successful
automation and not so high level yes we
can do that I don't think the Q&A
session now is the right forum and for
that please that user I would really
appreciate if you provide contact
details and we get back to you we'll sit
down and evaluate exactly what you need
to automate and we will come up with a
solution will be able to have some
references for you that show what we've
done today and then we can take it a
step further thank you so much dr. over
camp we appreciate this great Q&A
session do you have any final comments
for our audience no I I don't have any
final comments I think I I enjoyed it I
hope everybody has seen that laboratory
automation really is a it can be a key
tool to be more efficient in signs of
the day the request I mean the science
environment has changed right so there
is more and more data are required these
days to be able to give a scientific
publication these data need to be very
robust they need to be handled with
statistical approaches for data analysis
etc cetera all of that only makes sense
if you can generate data that you can
trust that are reliable and laboratory
automation is definitely a key tool to
enable the generation of such data thank
you again doctors over camp I'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions and
a big thank you to our sponsor beckman
coulter life sciences for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on demand through May
twenty seconds 2017 collaborates will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live events that'll
make you for joining us and we hope to
see you next time goodbye goodbye